[Music]
did you check out the Super Bowl last
night I'm imagining you watched it why I
didn't buy that at all did you
why which part come on san Francisco's
getting their butts handed to them and
then they come back and there's a 93
yard run back and then the lights go out
and then they go on to almost almost win
yeah
you think oh wait so you've got like a
conspiracy theory going here I did a
little research I you know I don't
appreciate people that that are
conspiracy junkies but I did some
research okay San Francisco yes he's in
California the hard part the governor of
California is Jerry Brown yes Jerry
Brown dated Linda Ronstadt yes Linda
Ronstadt grew up in Tucson Arizona her
brother Peter was the police chief of
Tucson during his tenure as police chief
they remodeled part of the court house
one of the electricians that worked on
that course house was named Sergio nasal
rod now I had trouble finding that much
about sergio nage alive except that he
had a very contentious divorce from his
wife who grew up where baltimore
maryland after a few years ago he moved
down to New Orleans after Katrina to do
electrical work the Superdome had huge
damage after Katrina guess where nasal
Rod was born where San Francisco I rest
my case
it's all in the Internet that piece of
paper has nothing on it fudge recipe
just guessing I didn't see I'm standing
by my story thank you so much for being
here you know I want to ask you we
wouldn't talk a little bit about
shameless and I think you play them
beautifully this character Frank but it
must be a fun character to play because
you get to sort of break all the rules
an incredible Boozer first of all what
do you drink yourself what is William H
Macy drink I'm pretty discriminating I
think malted Scotch whisky is the
greatest thing mankind has ever done so
I pretty much malted scotch whiskey I'll
drink I'll drink vodkas sometimes you
know like at a party or or if it's some
sort of a Mexican theme I'll drink
tequila mm-hmm okay so wine you know or
wine why not hear if there's it the
occasion call so malted scotch whiskey
tequila wine but that's it yeah sambuca
[Laughter]